hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to catharsis a game that
features your darkest nightmares the
creepy crawlies underneath your bed
the man staring your window right now
those that watch you as you sleep get
out of here now well I'm not one to be
asked twice about anything so I'm just
gonna scurry on my way well then mine
what you look at red vignette means you
losing consciousness very fast blue
means your condition is getting better
hole left right mouse button to use your
arms touch something to grab it
okay can I touch my fans check every
door press e key to crowds and spaced
jump okay okay don't look at the weird
tentacle monster on the wall that's
definitely no no hello oh these things
disappear when I look on them for a
while I remember it's from somewhere
well then I've been hello what is this
why did this fall on the ground over
there
I have arms I can use my armies my
armies okay enough of that I need to
move to che to pick it up I'm trying to
- che it yeah I'm trying to get my oh I
got it
yes I get all that's so cool okay so a
Sally oh okay
kind of forgot I was playing hard game
for just a second there you can back up
a second I know I saw something you
can't tell me I didn't oh good
mysterious whispering tell me try to
reach out without my hand yeah I know I
know the Fanta for this one is go okay
hooch and pull by going back let me
touch it oh the two chiton Boosh this
door all over the place come on oh I was
supposed to push it forward
my mistake this game is okay what the
heck what pardon for just one frickin
frakkin second what the hole okay okay
I'm not going crazy that was weird
what the hell this happened I fell oh
hey don't lose consciousness here I was
hitting myself in a head with a rock
thanks for coming along and give me good
advice what the hell just happened oh my
god
that is weird okay now I need to jump Oh
a pig okay I'm good
I am moderately disturbed I have no idea
what's going on and I am very confused
why was a oh [ __ ] okay why was why is
anything excuse me mr. Rock can I - whew
I'm just gonna touch you out of the way
my beatable all skills are unmatched but
my t22 skills are just about getting
ready to be epic it is all like a dream
but why feelings are so real why can't I
wake up maybe this is hell oh can I
touch this bottle of water can I touch
this broom can I touch this bookshelf
I'm touching everything with my hand I
touched this book uh I can't read that
nothing is constant look for changes in
places you've already visited the exit
is just like your mind tricky oh I'm
gonna touch that I'm gonna look at
though okay I have to look at them to
make them disappear
it won't budge well maybe if I change my
oh hello wait a minute was that always
there and why can't I see a damn doll
throw books at me I will touch you so
hard
don't make me touch you I got my chores
here was that it's a barrel Oh I entered
the no gravity part of the world iron
lowered part of the wild my teaching
abilities it was that was it
scrappy goes yeah sorry I'm sorry I'll
learn not to do CH you do CH this I'm
gonna torch everything in the world
watch out on the craze but to Chur
what's over here what's already what
sorry didn't mean to walk in uneasy big
glowing eye you want me to touch your
eyeball I can do trill good I'm the best
Duchin well what am I supposed to do
about that do i touch the door into the
eyeball or do I just not look at it I
guess I just don't okay give me crazy
but teacher walking through did I do for
him what the hell is dark oh I touched
it open oh can I touch the other one
please yes both doors need to be touched
open I'm gonna looki no no no no I'm
gonna look at you no look at you there
we go look that you good I'd uh oh no
it's happening in this game I'm very
confused and it's very dark I don't know
what's going on can I get out now
what do I do everything it looks
different than it water wise rocks over
here okay so I went this way I can't see
anything it's so dark
oh okay not there alright so if I go
this way no what is it
you know what made it to chip I can't
touch this oh I can pull it open oh god
it's just a brick wall let me close that
up there this game is weird this game is
weird sahabat don't you dare
I've got touching skills like you and
mine mmm I suppose openings I am
there's a guy I need to stare at
creepily I got him what's over here
oh you're different than the other ones
I'm trying to stare at you they're
intensely but it doesn't seem to be
working
can't do Cho I can touch him Wow
what okay die this is not what I wanted
here I'm not the only what you think I'm
doing I'm trying to touch him okay I
love it
oh no one like me touch huh oh my god
dude what do I do with the dude oh
please don't make me lose consciousness
oh how do I touch you right oh that just
goes into the abyss doesn't it close
that up there okay it's gonna stay open
for a little bit who's good with you I
wish I could see something so bloody
dark won't budge good oh I am like 50%
creeped out 50% utterly confused about
everything in though
what's that there's something front of
me what is that what is that what is
that who's like a person I will be to
below Taguchi it's not a person I just
sighs apartheid
oh good lordy what do I do why is he
louder okay gonna go back No
okay
okay
is the dude still there
wait a minute where the hell in mine I
don't know where the hell I am so I get
turned around somehow
it's did I somehow did I somehow run
into the dude Oh what is happening to me
why is everything changing Oh
why is everything changing oh I
literally can't see where I'm supposed
to go oh oh wait I've been here oh I'll
go this way now you'll boo boo shudder
mouse are people trying to die live
doors locked keys
I don't know what that means how the
hell am I told you know everything
doesn't want to stay the same
oh I just went in the world's biggest
circle I as I go back now oh okay so if
I go back this way will my consciousness
level is very low
find something to restore it what what
what is that that doesn't look like
conscious friendly crap oh is that a key
okay couch to go you son of a bear
change up now gonna let me torch you I'm
gonna torch Oh God
just let me touch you I got the best
touching hands come on oh you're right
there
torch it up damn it you're moving around
on me oh don't think I know your tricks
don't think I know your tricks don't
they got on all your drinks oh come back
here come back here you little scamp
I gotcha I gotcha this time on Oh Oh
fell through the floor
that was good for me delay in heaven
okay so if I go back I should be able to
try to poach it so I gotta try to touch
it from behind is what I'm getting that
I gotta somehow change up the
perspective of this world oh I'm gonna
do the world maybe I gotta go Andre oh
maybe I can touch it from underneath
okay I'm sorry
did not mean to pick up that key where
am I Oh Ziggy Ziggy did IATI
okay my okay things are going in and out
and in and now oh god I'm so sorry
everybody this is so disorienting the
good
you know what frankly good cuz I don't
know how much more of that I could have
taken Oh get me how do I have the key
still please tell me I solved the key
right nope don't want to be in here now
there's a bad idea I'll cast off the key
god I have o depending on whether or not
I cut that out because it was just so
sickening I was like the vision was just
warping in and out and it was making me
about to puke so I did not want to
subject you guys do that okay so now I'm
going to find the hole for this key
stick it in it and then go home that's
my current plan I'm sticking to it
I did it I touched it good did I win the
touching game did I touch enough to go
home can I go home now what's that
I saw shadow oh maybe it was my shadow I
don't know I'm getting kind of creeped
out at things I don't quite like this
very much I wanna go home now oh oh what
why what happened why did the cavern
explode on my face it squished me that's
what it did it squished me I need to
make it not squish me because not
squishing me is preferable okay so we
need to go out sideways maybe
backwards backwards good okay nothing is
constant okay I get it I get it I get it
okay so I'm probably supposed to go down
and then back up Oh what the hell wait a
minute
what huh okay now I'm confused now I'm
really gonna be oh so I go back up now
huh what Oh okay nope sorry
for the best hello
don't look at them it only makes them
faster don't look at them it only makes
them faster look at who look at who okay
oh oh whoa
where we going I don't know what I'm
doing I don't know where I'm going I do
not know anything about what I'm doing
right now okay oh god I'm gonna puke
again all maneuver arm I'm down okay
well that was a fun exercise let's never
do that again well what's going on no no
no don't look at that okay so now go out
this way cuz oh whatever right
Yolo where am I going what am i doing
did all the doors break open I need to
find the one I need to go down oh sorry
sorry sorry didn't know that was
occupied I apologize I apologize
Kazu Olin is the only one that didn't
open why oh god damn it not you Oh gonna
vomit all this oh oh oh okay so I found
a brick wall with the weird thing
sticking out of it what does that do for
me why am I here
huh hey well that's new yeah okay glad
that happened
can I do something bad
where am I going okay don't look at that
whoa do not look at that that is weird I
want to look at it but it's weird okay
get that healing juices fast off the
lighting crap in my brain oh good this
is somehow worse Oh God
I would be enjoying myself a lot more if
this game wasn't so sickeningly
disorienting all the time where me is
that just going into nothingness that
just goes into the abyss doesn't it oh
come on
Oh give me the right way to go shut up
shut up you know what shut up where are
you who are you where am i what am I
doing here I can't see anything okay
thank you that illumination was greatly
appreciated but what the hell I am so
confused I don't understand it okay
thank you oh good a brick wall am I just
supposed to go back and forth over and
over again chasing ah hello what does
that do
does that hurt this weird big thingy oh
so you're not an eyeball anymore you're
just a big wittily oh hello the way out
exit exit exit get me out err no let me
touch you let me touch the light I want
to walk towards the touch
let me through you let me through thank
you cheese come on okay that was both
infuriating and intriguing
holy crap I found six of twelve statues
well everybody that was catharsis you
make that of that whatever you will
because I am utterly confused so I hope
you enjoyed it nonetheless thank you so
much for watching check out my other
scary games in the scary games playlist
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
what